(upbeat music)
- Oakland really will chew you
up and spit you out like...
like it's nothing, you know?
People get killed every day.
You know, living in Oakland,
nothing is promised tomorrow.
So if I'm gone tomorrow, what
legacy would I leave behind?
My name is Tyrone Stevenson
also known as Baybe Champ,
the Scraper Bike King,
and I'm the founder
and CEO of the Original
Scraper Bike Team.
- I ride because it's my lifestyle.
- I don't know, it just
makes me express myself
even more.
- We work with youth that
lives in the community
and teach them how to make their bicycles.
For students, for kids
to be a part of the team,
you have to have at least a 2.0 GPA.
Some of them like it, some of them don't,
but at the end of the
day they have to respect
it if they wanna be a part of this team.
- We use different bike
parts to make one big one
and make it look better.
I can basically fix
anything on a bike now.
- Scraper Bike Team teaches
youth how to customize
their bikes, put aluminum
foil and duct tape
and spray paint on the
bike, and make a nice bike.
Scraper Bike is bigger
than this life, a regular
bike is just a regular bike.
- I ride Scraper Bike because
I like the way they look.
- You get to show it off and
say you made it yourself.
- Yesterday was our grand
opening of The Shed,
the first youth brand bike shop ever
in Oakland.
I founded the Original
Scraper Bike Team officially
in 2007, yeah, me and my cousin Avery.
It's a bittersweet feeling
to open up The Shed,
just knowing that my
cousin Avery isn't around.
Just to see it, just to
have his presence here.
Because he was killed, he was murdered.
Senseless, he didn't have
nothing to do with nothing.
I feel like this whole
movement is dedicated to him.
And I do this because one
day I might not be here,
and somebody else can step into
my place and keep it going.
(upbeat music)